hello everybody hope you are good a new
day a new update for Bitcoin these are
the levels that I marked yesterday in my
chart and maybe you wonder why I think I
explained it in the video but basically
uh below this one's here there is a lot
of liquidity okay why because this is
the zones where the retail Trader is
gonna play the stop losses all right so
it's very likely to see these kinds of
aviations okay the V8 then get a backup
of it test it a support and then you can
go higher okay that's what this arrows
mean okay this indicates you that there
might be some deviations in this Zone
you have to look for those but also
if you lose this Zone okay and you
consolidate below the resistance then
you're gonna go to the next level Okay
then if you would have done here then
you could be looking for deviations here
okay again if that doesn't work you know
consolidation below resistance and then
drop lower all right since it's as
simple as that so uh this is what I like
to keep
in my distribution Zone because
sometimes I can give you an idea of what
you want to look for potential traits
and you know I don't have to tell you
sometimes that it's going to go up and
down because sometimes it's impossible
to know you just have to wait you know
prepare a plan of two scenarios you know
deviation or break lower consolidation
below resistance and then you drop to
the next level okay so if you have a
plan like this you're considering both
scenarios this is going to make you be
able to trade both directions okay in in
two Longs if there is a division or into
shorts if you break below this one all
right so um that's pretty much what
we've seen now the problem that I have
with this move is if we're going to the
one hour time frame okay here you also
have
um this week over here it got filled
with this with the next candle okay and
test it as support okay that's your
signal to go along so you can always go
into a lower time frame uh to look for
confirmation entries now this is the
problem that I have here and is that if
you notice this pump here
it has been during the Asian session
okay and you can see the London
it's you know it's doing another push
higher so let's see how this ends up for
just so you know this ACM pumps usually
tend to get retraced uh I don't know if
it's gonna be today or not usually if it
was today what you want to see is London
holding here
okay hold in here and then New York is
when they can set this move all right
but you can see the London continuous
pumping
so let's see how London finishes London
still has let me check how long around
two hours and a half of trading so if
they close up of here all right then we
would say that London has pumped also so
you have Asia pumping London pumping
if that happened then you know it's
likely that New York continues to pump
okay and that will take you to this
liquidity pool over here all right so
that's the one problem that I see with
this pump is the ACR pumped and I don't
trust pumps during the Asian session and
also again I talked about this yesterday
but you can see that
what they kept doing is you know large
Scandal they retrace that Scandal they
retrace again large Scandal they retrace
more large candles in this Zone the
retrace and others are in the same okay
you're having another large green candle
right why is this telling you okay
they're telling you that maybe they look
they retrace from here or they might
continue pumping here with another large
candle and then they can retrace okay
that's what it's telling me and ours is
telling me that the market maker is
essentially building his swords with
these large candles okay by making a
little Trader believing
that price is gonna go to higher prices
okay so be very careful I think that in
the midterm uh it's more likely that we
see you know I don't know if you want to
go to this liquidity pool will not do
something like this okay or maybe like
this I don't know but I think that in
the midterm
price is probably gonna break lower all
right
that's what I think the market maker is
doing I think the market making this
building his shorts with these large
green candle so that's my theory I might
be wrong with this one we'll see how I
place out well at the minute that what
the chart is telling me okay and of
course
um that will be invalidated the idea
would get invalidated if we break above
this one okay and even if you
considerate it over here you know that's
telling you that we want to see higher
prices and that's when people can see
their beloved 32k 32.5k that they're
talking about all right but for now I'll
tell you that I will tell you to be very
cautious here
don't be euphoric don't be very
optimistic and very bullish because uh
these large candles
in consolidation of the highs is telling
you that
they are set in a Range to prepare
shorts okay and even more interesting
you look at this let me remove all of
this
um let's see if this is some kind of
range
let me see so imagine this is the
um the range low
okay let's see what the middle of the
range is
okay so this would be the middle of
range
let me do it like this so you can see
okay
that's the middle of the range
you can see that in this Zone
okay you've I mean it's quite a solid
Zone because you have here resistance
resistance support support resistance
support resistance
you see what I mean guys
you see what I mean this is a range okay
again with my camera here support we can
continue support continue higher okay
then with my drop tester resistance okay
this is a range at the moment
now what happens in the ranges
usually we see deviations okay so that
could tell you the idea but it's
possible to see a deviation at highs
before dropping okay before breaking
below this range okay that's another
possibility now let's try to be
even more specific with this range let's
see if this ivr works so I want to know
now the quarters of the range okay
let's have to find those levels let's
see if this makes some kind of sense
okay so this could be uh sorry this
could be a quarter of the range and
let's see the other quarter of the range
okay I just want to see if this makes
sense in the chart with the levels
okay and we can take also these levels
as a strong support and resistance zones
so that will be over there
um Fibonacci we can remove it and let's
try to change
the color
maybe to Orange nah blue for example
something a bit different
okay
um I mean to me makes sense because you
can see here
I mean here resistance
here after resistance resistance okay
and here you can see support support
support
right
so these are the levels right now in the
in the chart we are in a Range okay you
can divide the range into two halves or
into quarters okay that's up to you but
you can see that right now
what is inside in this range
so that is telling you okay that if
price comes out of this Zone above here
okay this should be our resistance okay
now if you can be if you can flip this
level then you're gonna go into into
this high right and probably see a
deviation
let me tell you something guys I think
that if we
let me remove this I think that remember
this is the or liquidity pool that we
think it has to get filled sooner or
later because when there is a liquidity
pool at highs that usually tells you
that the market make it is when I
revisit this this prices you know later
okay they are not finished in this zone
so that is a liquidity pullover
market for you
that's the liquidity puller and it's as
simple as this if price comes higher
finish this liquidity pool and then it
goes higher then
you know the most likely thing is that
we see a deviation here right
that's what I'll be looking at okay look
for a deviation here
that's what I have a right number in my
mind
I've seen that is likely that
uh price comes to I'm finished this
liquidity pool and if it goes higher
then be ready for that deviation
okay but in the midterm I think that we
have to fill all these imbalances here
okay check out these songs how many
liquidity pools you got here okay even
all the way to 70 to 27k
all right that's what I think guys uh I
don't know if I'm gonna be right or
wrong with this one uh but at the moment
this is my opinion okay uh I don't know
if you want to also Mark these levels
here in the range but they're playing
pretty nicely and that could
um help you to identify potential
entries and of course take profits now
let's go into high block Capital let's
see if we can find something interesting
there
let's check if there is liquidity here
okay
um hang on let me zoom in a bit more
okay I see some liquidity all the way to
thirty thousand eight hundred twenty
five eight hundred fifty and also low
okay at 30 225 so what I think today is
that one of these Stones is gonna get
taken okay maybe even both of them right
if both of them get taken then what it
makes more sense is to attack this
liquidity Zone first at highs thirty
thousand eight hundred fifty ish okay
and then they can come for this one okay
but I think thirty thousand eight
hundred twenty five is probably uh gonna
get taken today that's what I think uh
now if you're going to the seven days
time frame
let's have a look at this
okay
wow that's a lot of liquidity uh twenty
nine thousand six hundred
uh wow okay let me go to the chat now
but I think that's
um at the week let me check quickly
29 600. oh yes I see that's basically in
the sun here the range lows okay uh I
would say that that's basically because
you know they're having visit this Zone
for a while so there is a lot of
liquidity here also if you go into the
four hour time frame they're gonna be
able to see the there is a week here
okay
this week here check it out this week is
probably gonna get filled okay it was a
candle that it was a bit strange because
you have a quick to the website and to
the downside the week two Loops that go
filled straight away but the one to the
downside didn't so anyway guys let me
remove this wrench okay we're gonna go
into the four hour time frame uh what
the chart is telling me is the work
really uh
this liquidity pool here
okay that's your liquidy pool and you
know while also in a range between sorry
in a range between these two levels here
Okay so
if we you know if we retrace this
liquidity pool and then price doesn't
dump okay then the next short
opportunity would be a deviation of the
highs and that's when you know price
will go lower to the range lows okay and
usually when there is a deviation in one
of the ends of the range then you
usually see a Breakout
in the other end of the range okay so
that's telling me that if we say
deviation
then it's likely the price breaks lower
okay breaks out to the alongside sorry
uh that's what I think at the moment I
don't see many trading opportunities
um for today to be honest uh so far what
I can see is that you have to be close
use with these large scandals because
they retrace them pretty quickly this
moves you can see
okay so you have to be very careful with
these moves also it was you know all
this on here this pump was during the
Asian session so be careful with that
and uh of course you know they're gonna
face some resistance on the way but I
think that sooner or later this might
not be for today maybe for another day
but I think that when I come to this
liquidity pool before uh coming low okay
you can trade the range that I showed
you that's quite safe to trade because
you've seen that the levels have been
playing out pretty nicely and also to be
cautious
because
uh don't jump into shorts too early
because I'm telling you there is a big
chance that we come to this liquidity
pool or even uh sweep this size okay
uh so yeah uh pretty remote Trader range
guys thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you soon